there's three ways you can get leads
right one is you can manually assemble
the leads list the second way is that
you can buy leads from Brokers the third
way is that you can scrape leads using
software for me I usually will start
[Music]
with Zev what's up man how's it going
good I have two questions um sort of
both different topics but the first one
is more lead related struggling to
figure out which method is the best
method to focus on so I don't feel like
I'm wasting my time you know doing
something
um to try to get leads who are you going
after the three main avatars would be
like Tech startups B2B b2c SAS and then
really any company that has like a
custom uh software so there's three ways
you can get leads right one is you can
manually assemble the leads lists the
second way is that you can buy leads
from Brokers the third way is that you
can scrape leads using software I
usually will start with uh scraping if I
can um because it tends to be the
cheapest and so I'll use like if you
just Google tool 4 whatever ever like
what you're referring to yeah yeah and
then I'll take the top four or five of
them and I'll run my search for avatars
into each of them and then I'll take a
sample of like let's say 100 or 500
leads of each work all of them see which
ones I get the highest response rate and
then I'll double down on whatever
platform got me the highest throughput
you're saying which platform gets you
the highest response rate that we were
referring to which lead Source yeah I
mean in terms of reaching out to the
actual leads itself I reach out on
everything that sort of ties into next
thing so one thing I've been thinking
about is you know how you talk about to
lead with sort of with value offer
something essentially for free so that's
like a big thing where I'm just like not
really sure how to even figure out what
we could offer being that like am I like
stepping is this like no you're good
this is like I go through this literal
step-by-step process in the book of
everything that you're saying so it's
like how to figure out what you're going
to give the person for free how to
structure it how to make like here's the
script to get replies all that stuff um
so the good news is the book will solve
your problem but the best framework that
I can use for coming up with things that
people will reply to is give them
Something Free that they would normally
pay for so rather than be like I made
this amazing thing but if it's the same
free valuable thing that everyone else
gives then how you know how good is it
you have to compete by being
significantly better but if you just do
something that normally other people
charge for even on a micro level and
they can ascribe real value to that
people will respond to you and then then
you're operating on a you're you're in a
way better frame and then you can have a
much better conversation the other thing
was more like on a personal side so we
could just sort of step back when you
were sort of going through that you know
volatility of you had like success then
big failures and come back up in terms
of how you like structured your life if
you did at all so that you P put
yourself in the best position to where
like you're cutting certain people out
maybe you're bringing certain people or
that might be even resources for skill
development or whatever in how do you go
about doing that so that you're not um
doing things that don't really help you
move forward and grow long-term big
picture yeah so it's a it's a really
good question because the number one way
to change your behavior is to change
your environment so if you change the
conditions you'll behave differently
right like if there's a red light you
act differently than a green light and
so that's a micro example of how we act
like in Baltimore when I live there I
act differently than when I move because
I had I've had a clean slate like I
didn't have to talk to old friends that
would treat me a certain way that then I
would respond to in the way that I
didn't want to right and so first thing
from a people perspective like I think a
lot can be gained from literally just
moving 30 minutes away like even if you
like I can't move out of you know I'm
not going to move from Baltimore to
California okay that's fine just move to
the other side of town just get just get
out of the micro environment the second
thing that'll then lead to is the people
that you will frequent will change right
and I think that you'll have to get
accustom or be okay with the fact that
you will lose a lot of friends and
that's not a bad thing because the thing
is is like if if all you have in common
continues to shrink and shrink and
shrink and the only thing you have left
to talk about is the past remember the
good old times remember that time we got
so drunk at rippies you know what I mean
like whatever then like they're not
trying to help you create the future
that you were ultimately looking for and
it just like I will say that as I've
gotten you know further along in that
path my time to cutting people has just
shrank because if I figure if I'm going
to cut this person eventually I might as
well cut them now and start enjoying the
benefits of of not having them in my
life and having all this back and it's
like all those time if I have somebody
who just keeps inviting me to and
then making me feel guilty if I go out
and they're like why aren't you drinking
or like why aren't you like oh he's on
another diet you know whatever it's just
like you're not help like just asking
the question like how do you think what
you're saying is going to help me and if
there's like well I'm just giving you a
hard time it's like yeah understood how
is that going to help me it's not okay
so like either change your behavior or I
will change it for you meaning I will
just not have you in my life the third
piece is that I remember there's this
video I had just uh opened my six
location and I was looking to open 7
through 10 and I had already mapped out
where I was going to be opening them for
my for my gyms and I remember I did this
Facebook live and I was like beat up you
know what I mean like I was tired I was
taking I was doing 12 hours a day is a
sale so I was taking sales sales from 8
to 8 every day and then I would still do
the rest of my work before and after
that and somehow trying to work out
during that period I remember saying
what are you willing to give up so I
made this live it was like these are all
the things I'm giving up now so like
these are things that I used to do that
I'm not going to be doing anymore so I
was like I'm not folling the Ravens
anymore so I was bore Ravens I was like
I'm not I'm not watching football I'm
not looking at Fantasy I'm not going to
build a team I'm just on Sundays I need
to work like I can't give the three hour
I can't do it so I gave up football I
gave up Netflix I was like that night
time where like normally I like de you
know decompressed I was like I don't
have time for that right now like I got
a process payments I got processed
contracts I got filed with leads and do
reminders for the next day and so it was
changing where I was places wise being
okay with the fact that I was going to
have a period of a little bit more
solitude because as soon as you cut
things you create room you create a
vacuum but new people will come in who
are like in this world and I would
recommend just connecting with people
online because there's so many there's
such bigger communities of people who
are trying to do the same thing online
versus wherever you're at locally right
and then the third is it's just like
what are my behaviors what are the
things I'm going to give up in order
like CU you got to make room like you
only have 24 hours right so it's like
what are the things that aren't getting
me where I want to go and the thing is
if you just say I'm not going to do
those positive behaviors will fill the
gap think for me it comes to more maybe
a family side of things like those
people I have a different way of dealing
with them their family but like I don't
know how to necessarily navigate that so
two things first off I have very extreme
views on this so like just take that
with the great of Sal that that you will
right if we Zoom all the way out like I
didn't choose to be born that was forced
on me and so like I don't feel like I
owe anyone for that right now that being
said I believe in Fair exchange or
abundant exchange meaning like I'm going
to make everybody in my life's life
better for being there but I want them
to also make my life better right and so
I think the first layer of this is
approaching it with absolute cander
which is like what you would tell me
being like man my dad you know he just
treats me like I'm a kid he always
brings up these things like when I was
14 years old and he keeps saying oh you
know zev's got a short temper you know
like my dad says that he's like you such
a short temper right he used always tell
me that and so you have to reset like
you have to reset B like these are the
rules of engagement like if you want me
and in your life this is what is
required from me which is like you
cannot speak to me this way like if you
know your your big Uncle grabs you by
the neck and he's like look a little
Nuggie you know whatever something like
I'm not saying he's doing that but I'm
saying as an extreme example like what
would you do there you you're like No
And it creates like it creates a moment
where they're like oh now they'll then
probably try and shake it up like dude I
was just kidding it's like it wasn't
funny I'd be like it's just you and me
and I'm not laughing and it's like whoo
that's a new tone right and so like you
have to reset boundaries have to reset
the Rules of Engagement and then the
thing is is that you have to enforce
those which means that at a certain
point you have to decide that I'm going
to decrease my communication Cadence I'm
going to decrease my proximity to you
I'm not going to be as I'm not going to
be as accessible when you text me might
take me a couple days to respond right
when you say hey you got a minute I
might not have a minute right like you
have to earn that and like the fact that
you are family gives you morally way but
not infinite and so one of the
unfortunate things about family is that
we treat family worse than anyone else
because we think that we can't lose them
and so I reject that notion entirely I
just I just don't I I believe in
treating everyone the same family and
stranger and then if I can benefit them
awesome and if they can benefit me
awesome and then we both keep Like
Loving our relationship because we don't
feel like we're owed anything and so
that's that's bir directional though
because that's the thing is if you're
going to play this game in my opinion
this is the way I play it which is that
you're like listen I don't owe you stuff
but it means I'm also not going to say
you owe me anything and like we're
starting there that's how I approach
those things thanks for taking my
questions appreciate it you bet s
appreciate you good luck
man hey Alex how is it going Selena
what's going on how do you strike the
balance between offering free value to
pay offers like when is the perfect time
to make that switch so you give until
they ask simple as that you give and you
keep giving and you keep giving and you
keep giving until eventually people are
like dude what else do you have can I
get this from you like dude you've
helped me so much like could is there
and what happens is you'll start hearing
what different people want from you and
then you'll start noticing the common
thread and then you can ask permission
from your audience of the people that
you are providing this value to and be
like hey if I did something like this
would you guys be interested and then
take a take a poll very easy right and
if they say lots of them say yes then
it's like now you have permission from
the audience to then say cool well I'm
going to go spend 3 months building this
for you and I'm going to get it to you
guys just because you give things away
for free does not mean that everything
that you do is free we give free stuff
in order to get more people interested
and earn more trust so that on a longer
time Rising we can convert more people
into customers a purchase decision it's
a prediction of future value right like
I'm going to buy this thing cuz I
believe that after I buy it
I'm going to get in excess of whatever I
paid for right and the best way to
increase some increase someone's
conviction that they're going to get
value from you in the future is to
provide it value to them in the present
yeah and so that's the that's the whole
game and so I'll give you I'll give you
a different example so if I were to go
up to 100 people and say hey uh buy my
thing right I might get one person to
buy it because I might have caught them
on a good day and they're really
struggling whatever right if I go to the
same 100 people and say hey can I solve
one of your problems for free
more than one person will say yes maybe
20 people will say yes and then from
those 20 people when you crush it for
them and then say hey by the way I
solved this first problem you now have
another problem that's a better problem
but it's still a problem and I can solve
that for you too in exchange for money a
way higher percentage of that 20 will
now take you up on the offer and then
you get half of those 20 to buy your
thing and you go from one sale talking
to 100 people to 10 sales so you can 10x
your conversion rate by just adding a
level of trust prior to the ask how do
you come up with that idea and think
about okay I'm going to give this for
free and you have the idea you have the
idea honestly like okay I'm going to I'm
going to dive a little a level
underneath is that you're not accustomed
to the level of work that's required
like real talk you're just not used to
it and that's okay my level of output
and my understanding of how much work
capacity I have has continued to
increase over time I have put 200 hours
into the presentation that I'm going to
be giving on Saturday yeah most most
people don't put 200 hours into their
product it's just it's just orders of
magnitude in terms of difference and so
like if people saw how much time I put
into the things they wouldn't be
surprised by the value yeah they'd be
like well that makes sense he spent 200
hours on actually I'm a little
embarrassed for the guy he spent he
spent basically five weeks of work hours
to make one you know 90-minute
presentation and so I think that if you
were to think about like for you to
actually spend legitimately like working
hours spend 200 hours on making
something really good and that doesn't
mean making it longer it means making it
better and then give that away for free
yeah and then what happens is if it
really is good people will then share it
with other people and then you get
double effect you get more people to
take you up on the free offer and then
their friends send you other people
there's so much more work that goes into
it I spent six hours a day for two years
on this next book I I work from 6:00 to
noon every day and then I take my
meetings I did that every day for 2
years
and now I'm releasing the book right and
I feel very confident that it's a good
it's a very good product right and so
again I think my level of work in terms
of hours is probably greater than what
you're doing and I have a lot of stuff
going on right but you just have to be
able to block the time and say the first
four hours of my day every day for this
month are making this thing and I'm
going to make you exceptional and the
thing is document you making it show
people how much work you're putting into
it and then when you do have it they're
like like wow she really did this she
didn't just whip up a PDF that took her
a day I used to think that a day of like
oh this took me a whole day a whole day
in my mind was a long time and the nice
thing is that the the really valuable
fruit are right in front of everyone it
just has a very tall ladder so you just
have to climb a lot longer than other
people will to go pick the fruit but
it's right in front of you you just have
to spend way more time making the thing
exceptional which also means that all
the other distractions that you're
probably distracted on right now the
little side projects this is me just
guessing right now right you have to cut
that because what you realize is the
amount of work that's required to make
something exceptional prudes you from
doing multiple things yes like you can't
do multiple things well you can do one
thing exceptionally well and that means
that you have to say no to everything
else yeah how do you find that
exceptional thing then it's not that you
find it you make it the more you do the
better you get and the more you pull the
thread on any of the things that you're
interested in the deeper you'll go on it
because you will get better at it by
very the very fact of how much volume
you're putting into it so whatever it is
that you help people with the one that
makes you the most money right now
ignore everything else ignore the other
opportunities and say like how do I how
do I make this even easier like think
about the value equation how do I make
it faster for them how do I make it less
effort for them how do I increase their
perception of the likelihood that
they're going to succeed which means
that you know what I've been offering
one product but I really have three
avatars and so I need to just make this
tiny tweak here so that this person and
this person and this person will be be
successful now if I was going to lean in
even more I would say just pick one of
the three and then exclude the other
ones just Master a puddle just be queen
of a puddle and then you can be queen of
a pond and then queen of a lake and then
queen of a bay and then queen of an
ocean right like but you got to start
with the puddle cuz you're like half in
half out between different ones figuring
out what's my thing that I'm really
really good at and like spend a lot of
time on and perfecting that don't even
think the thing that you're really good
at cuz you might not be that good at
anything right now and I'm not saying
that as a I'm not that's not a WRA I'm
just saying like that's not a dig I'm
saying do the one that you forget about
time while you're doing it and then you
will become
excellent because you'll be able to
actually keep working like you have to
solve for what is the thing that I can
work the most like this amount of work
is required to get where you want to go
right to be exceptional and so then what
you solve for is how can I find
something that I don't mind doing this
much work of but this much work is
required no matter
what and if you do this much work
whether you're learning to be the best
plumber or the best architect or the
best whatever weight loss coach that
like if you can do that and forget about
time you'll win when I started on
YouTube I told the guy that was editing
my thing I said listen I'll do I'll do
three videos a week for 10 years I was
like and then if we'll measure whether
it worked or not he's like I've
literally never had anyone say that so
like right now is just like you have you
need a perspective shift thank you so
much for the opportunity and thank you
so much for the answer
Joe what's up man how are you doing Alex
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
awesome uh my name's Joe I'm in the gym
space I'm in the brick and Water Gym
space the space you move I know some
stuff about it I know some stuff about
it and uh I'm one of those guys who uh
read gym launch a couple years too late
I'm a little older so I made all the
same all the mistakes you talking uh
talked about when I felt like when I
read the book I felt like I was reading
Deja Vu I was like oh my God all these
things happen to me so my question to
you is um me and my business partner Dan
are launching a series of semi-private
personal training Studios we're still in
that space and we're launching one
shortly and so using the hundred million
leads book that's coming out and some of
the stuff from JY launch and hundred
million do offers what would you do to
launch a gym our plan every six months
for the next few years uh you know until
we get a number that we're happy with
and we keep getting fun my my preference
my preferred model is one of two right
now you're already doing one of them so
I won't even get into the other one but
I love the semi-private model um I love
that like $300 $400 a month price point
um two to three times a week um I like
going
after avatars that have a little bit
more money specifically uh because for
them you know they're not going to not
pay during the holidays you know what I
mean like for them they're not going to
be like you know Breaking the Bank over
300 bucks um and the nice thing and I
think this is this is I I got this from
Rick rck uh Rick Mayo of alloy um that
model allows you to get to about 5
600,000 a year with you know 1,200 s
feet, 1400 ft like super small footprint
um and a single manager who's got maybe
10 20% profit share maybe like 40 50k
base and two helpers right so it's a
very simple lean model uh one on six one
on eight depending on how you want to do
it um and you all you have to do is get
to
120ish uh at the location and it's
usually 50% margin I mean I I have over
time simplified and simplified the model
so that there's just so little
operational complexity so that you can
scale and because of are you familiar
with dumb Bar's number yeah so the
reason I like this model is that like
most micro gims cap at 120 to 150 and
it's because the systems required to
purposely
manufacture human connection become
significantly more complex as you cross
that barrier right and so rather than
create this very very complex machine to
make it run at 600 you know service
based members I'd rather just have a
model that runs very profitably at 120
to 150 members and so um lead gen
perspective number one is that I would
do a three-month uh pre-launch number
two is that I would disproportionately
spend on the launch so I would I would
put like 30 grand um into the pre-sales
and I would open at full capacity the
best Jim franch rches know how to
pre-sell so that they are in the Black
in the first month and like every time I
opened a new location like it was the
first location was the one that I didn't
learn I learned the lesson on my first
one because I thought I was trying to
get it open as fast as possible so I
could make money but with everyone after
that I tried to do pre-sales as long as
possible so I could make all this money
and not have to pay any expenses and so
that way you can also Focus too cuz you
can just sell for 3 months do nothing
but work leads and and close contracts
and then after that you I'm sure you're
what's your turn right now for semis uh
right now only about 5% okay I mean I I
would shoot for three you know what I
mean but five's okay um you know if
you've got let's let's just say five
right and you're you got 120 members
it's six members a month you got to
replace like it's just like it it's so
easy to replace that um and just expect
like if if you have and what's your
price point monthly uh about 400 okay so
400 so that's an 8K LTV right in terms
of Revenue you're not profit but like 8K
LTV like you should be able to spend 500
bucks to a Car customer and not even
sweat on it and so like if you pay up to
100 bucks a lead local so that you can
close 20% of those into contracts I'm
not saying those are good numbers I'm
saying those are exaggeratedly bad
numbers you still be fine right because
even if you had to close Six customers
the month it's three grand a month in
ads just to maintain it's nothing now in
Jim want you talk about you know doing
your six week transformation do you
still recommend that as the primary
giveway because that's best has been the
rapper can change you know what I mean
like I always call it's just wrapping
paper on the present but like we're
still doing nutrition we're still doing
workouts so like whether I do you know 6
week 42 days 21 days 28 days you know
belly fat blast meta metabog reset like
you know slim by Halloween you know Lean
by Halloween you know what it is slim
for Santa you know big booty boot CIP
free sixe challenge 42-day detox like a
done them all like at the end of
the day like all of those are rappers
that you rotate locally just so that
your ads don't fatigue but you want to
always push it into the same sales
process so that the Ops don't change so
it's like the ad will change and then
you get on the phone you're like hey
what made you sign up for insert name of
promotion they're going to be like well
I'm kind of overweight and you're like
great what have you done so far right
and you start going through it so my
second question is you know with a
business partner who you know we have
kind of like a different personalties we
work really great together 17 years of a
great partnership how do we how do you
manage what would you recommend my my
preferred mode is take risk scale fast
like we we have momentum we're maxed out
in both our other gyms we have a great
local rep reputation and recognition and
I'm like let's do you know let's do 10
of these in the next like three years
and he's like loose his mind over it
like he's more of a pro it guy in your
experience you
know what's better you know speed yeah
or or or prove it you're both right a
good partnership has a yes man and a and
a no man right and so like in my Dynamic
with Lila it's like I'm yes she's no
right and that's basically how
everything gets managed if it were up to
me we joke like we would have a 100
businesses if we're up to her we'd have
none he says no because he's knows how
much work it is right like if you're the
promoter and the you know CEO whatever
you want to call it then there's usually
more like strategic works or leadership
stuff but in terms of like daytoday they
usually bear the brunt of the work and
so it costs more to them it's more
painful and so I'll I'll give you my
advice from what I would do having now
worked with an implementer for a long
time is I say what would you need to see
for us to be for you to feel comfortable
with us doing that and then she'll say
here's the checklist if you do these
things and you make sure these are the
things that are that are done we can do
the next one and then that way we have
an agreement and it's like and to be
clear if we do the same checklist at
location three you feel good again like
yeah I'm good again if we have these
things
and so and then you're and then you're
aligned and then it's like cool let's
just keep the party going that's perfect
yeah that's great that's great advice
thank you so much I'm really excited
book and and and grateful for everything
you've given out to the community of
strength for sure appreciate it man
thanks
Joe Nicole what's up I don't know if you
remember me we met at Eric Su yeah
Mastermind so since then I started a
podcast um doing pretty well I made most
my money as a Creator doing brand deals
so for example I was big in in the
crypto space the second I started my
podcast I had like a six-figure deal
which coming to an end I don't think
it's going to be renewed everyone that I
everyone that I talk to is like Nicole
you've grown on all these social Pages
um not just my personal but like you
know other brands that where I'm like
curating other people's content and
everyone's like it's a no
brainer do a newsletter um i t i to sill
Bloom for example you know who sells ads
in his and that's his his model um but
you know then I also heard you say
recently that like subscribers and
followers don't really mean anything
like they're a vanity metric and you're
like the game is now click retain reward
what exactly does that look like because
I like it's like currently I have
nothing to sell you you're good you're
good so it's it's it's two separate
applications so from the grow
perspective like growing the audience
getting more people to see your stuff
like that in that world subscribers I
mean Tik Tok has changed the game in
terms of how all the algorithms work
right like right now if you have 10
million subscribers on YouTube if your
next video sucks it's not going to get
views period yeah it works same thing
with Instagram you see people with 10
million per you know 10 million accounts
make a post and it's got 300 likes on it
right um it's because on the flip side
though it's good for new creators
because you can come on with zero
followers make a banging video and get
10 million views right and I I actually
think it's good thing for everyone
because it equalizes the playing field
it makes content King like the quality
of what you put out which I'm always
down to compete on that and so um so
that's from the growth perspective from
uh building out a newsletter like one is
top of funnel the newsletter subscribers
I mean that like those are customers you
know what I mean and so I I'm in no way
against having you know a new a
newsletter of any sort that provides
value especially to a nich audience cuz
um a buddy of mine um has a ton of data
on on subscriber stuff and like the ones
that do the best in terms of LTV and
whatnot are typically uh hyper Niche and
high value so usually a little bit
higher price point um but very specific
to like the because they are so Niche
they can provide an EXT like a lot of
value to a person versus being like
super wide it's very hard to provide
tremendous value to everyone right it's
kind of like Elon Musk thing of like you
can either provide a little bit of value
to a lot of people or a lot of value to
a few people and so I think if you feel
like you're better at a specific Niche I
I think I think it makes sense for you
to go top of funnel is just get really
good at making content and then that
just converts into your subscriber
network uh so your newsletter and then
you sell ads to the newsletter if you
want to from an endorsement perspective
you can also have your own products if
you want to um but you just become a
media business at that point which is
fine I mean I'm I'm a big fan of media
businesses okay that's really helpful
the other question that I had your
Dynamic is so different than what we
we've seen in like traditional
relationships yet it still works and you
guys kill it so what what's that Dynamic
like and how is it different and why do
you feel like you guys
Thrive we set out to solve a different
problem with our
relationship and so I think that the
premise that most people come into the
relationship with is different than how
Lea and I approach the relationship and
I think that's where I think fundament
like you know like when you're solving a
business problem I'm sure you probably
asked this it's like what problem are we
solving right it's like the first
question you ask is like what problem
are we solving and so most people don't
even a ask that but B if they do ask
that um they're usually trying to solve
a different thing they're like I want to
have lots of romance and this big
Hollywood love which from everything
that I know is something that is
shortlived and then disappears and then
you were left with someone that you were
looking at and you're like well
what do we have in common right and so
Lea and I had both rode that that roller
coaster multiple times before and we
like and we both were at a point where
we're like you know what and mind you I
was very you know dejected at the time
when I met her I was like listen I'm not
trying to do anything I'm trying to
build this this is what I'm doing and
the first 30 dates we had were 30 days
in a row where after our first date
where we went to frozen yogurt the next
date was not a date I was like I'm going
to be working from 9:00 until I go to
sleep so if you want to work with me you
can and so that was what we did every
single day is that I was like like I'm
going to be working if you've got work
we can work together and so it ended up
just being somebody that I enjoyed a lot
spending a lot of time with and the
romance stuff honestly I feel like
didn't really like kick in until like 2
and 1/2 years into our marriage and I
think that our relationship was based on
that like respect was first and then we
learned the love part it's very hard to
learn respect being hot or being
physically attracted to somebody I feel
like is the it's the ticket of Entry
it's not like I see a lot of successful
guys go find the the Instagram model I
meet said Instagram model and I'm like
how do you live like this like I would I
would kill myself if I had to talk to
this person every day right and they're
like oh the secret is I don't talk to
him I'm like that sounds horrible right
and so again it's like they were solving
a different problem and so for me my
goal is always has always been number
one like where I want to go right and
having somebody who wants to go that way
with you because I was engaged prior to
Leila right wonderful girl
um but we ultimately ended up deciding
to cut it off because we simply had
different goals for our lives she was
like I want to do this and I was like I
don't want to do that and it was like
what are you going to do and we're like
maybe you're a great person and I'm a
great person we're just not necessarily
like meant to be and that's okay because
I think on some level like we say these
things like non-negotiables but then we
negotiate and so it's like either it's a
non-negotiable or it is negotiable and
for me it's like where I want to go is
not negotiable so it's like I have these
goals which is where I want to go my
values which is how I want to get there
and then lifestyle which what are my
interests right and if I can find
somebody who wants to go the same place
the same way and have and likes doing
the daytoday the same way as me then I'm
good like the fact that Lela was into
fitness was like great I go to the gym
too you go to the gym like it's not
going to be weird you're not going to be
like oh I don't want to you know like
she's in the same mindset of that right
if I'm like hey I want to go invest in
this Workshop or something she's not
going to be like I can't believe we're
spending $110,000 on this it's
like that that person who would say that
is not my partner and I think um in
terms of me being the guy telling you
what like the number one thing that
attracted me about ilila was that Lea
never tried to change me if you want to
do big things then whoever is going to
come along with you has to be equally
big as a person and I think a lot of
people settle for a $45,000
employee I mean and you can even it's if
someone in the reverse if I were you and
someone's like man I'm looking for a
wife and I'd be like what are you
looking for out of a wife like talk like
not politically correct like what are
you actually looking for and so then if
they're like man I would love if someone
cooked and clean and and fed me and and
washed my clothes and iron and blah blah
blah blah blah you're like okay question
if I paid someone $45,000 a year to do
that
professionally then what would our
relationship
be cuz that that's an expense you know
what I mean like we can just write the
check and like all those things are
solved so like now
whaty Andy what's up man what is up Miss
Mr Alex Hermos okay so question I have
for you I've heard you talk a lot about
investing in the S&P me instead of the
S&P index like the Mi 500 right what
would you say with those skill
Acquisitions like which skills and in
what order would you suggest maybe a
person to go through because that kind
of ties into your skill stacking is
there a methodical way that you think
yeah this naturally ascends to the next
one I would think about it from the
order of how you would actually make
money so it's like well I have to have
something to sell right so you have to
have some sort of Base skill that you
could sell if you're going to get into
services or have some sort of based
product right once you know how to do
that so like if you're getting into
e-commerce you have to build a store
talk to manufacturers make the thing
that you're going to sell step one on
the services side it'd be like what's
the key skill that I'm going to acquire
to show people how to do it and you can
acquire that skill by like working a job
buying a certification going through a
course going to a workshop like I
learned I learned how to run Facebook
ads at a workshop you know what I mean
it cost me three grand um at the end of
the workshop I know how to run Facebook
ads and so and that $3,000 has made me
many more than $3,000 over the rest of
my career so point being first thing you
start with the thing right the second
thing you're going to do is that you
have to focus on promotion so it's going
to be advertising and if you think about
this is the order I did the books right
offers is what answers the question what
do I sell and leads answers the question
who do I sell it to right so like once
you have the thing then you got to go
sell the thing and let people know about
it and you have to advertise and so that
is that is that would be the second big
skill stack the third one would would be
conversion which is like kind of
persuasion so sales and there's
different ways you can do it so like you
could learn how to build you know
shopping pages in e-commerce that
convert you could take phone sales you
can learn how to to pitch and make vsls
all of those things and then finally if
you want to like learn the next piece
would be leadership and operations
because then you're going to have to
hire people to help you out with the the
caliber of people you work with and the
different levels that they're at has
there been anything that you would say
maybe is the common one or two missing
principles that most business owners are
not doing or if it's maybe questions
that they're not quite asking that you
like sometimes if you're only to do like
the one or two things not that they're
not all important what are they yeah so
I I just did a tweet the other day but
like the difference between you know a
thousand and a million uh is skills
right the difference between a million
and 100 million is character difference
between 100 million and a billion in my
opinion we'll see if it works is time uh
and so once you have the base skills
then it's really becomes about who the
person is and so as you scale up the
speed of scaling often correlates with
the speed of talent recruitment because
if you are a shitty person or a shitty
boss or a bad leader or can't have cast
division or can't explain why this is
going to benefit a lot of people not
just inside the business but also
outside the business then you're not
going to get the best people and if you
don't have the best people you have to
work overtime and then you never really
able to pull yourself out of the
business and so you can measure the qual
you know the size and the scalability of
the company by the talent that they can
attract like there's a reason that
Google and meta and Goldman Sachs and
all of these ones pull from from all the
Harvard you know all the IV League
schools and all that stuff and you know
we make fun of those people but they
also make all of the money and so it's
because they go they have a brand and
they have a huge pipeline of uh training
that they train people on and people
also know that when they go to that
brand Goldman Sach McKenzie whatever
that they're going to be able to go and
do whatever they want afterwards and so
like what happens is you realize that
there's a two-sided funnel right so on
one side you have to learn how to
attract customers but on the other side
you have to learn how to attract talent
because if you just only know how to
track customers then everything always
breaks and you can never get over the
hump and you can never scale brilliant
brilliant man well man thank you for
reaching back and helping all of us go
forward and taking the
shortcut uh how would you approach
creating strategies to generate leads
and cultivate enduring customer
relationships in this rapidly evolving
Enterprise B2B landscape right when I
say Enterprise let me clarify I'm
speaking to Fortune 500 uh Global 2000
type organizations I'll tell you two
very different things um on one hand
I've got a buddy who sells only to
Fortune 100 um and he was telling me
that one of their most profitable
strategies was hiring people from The
Fortune 100 in the Departments that
they're trying to get on board and then
they hire them and they already have all
the sway all the influence all the no
all the knoow and then they can bring
that account with them and then the
major majority of their revenue actually
just comes from cross- selling all the
different uh markets that those people
are in right so it's like okay I had to
start with you know Google Southwest
whatever right and then I have then I'm
moving on to Google Mexico Google latam
or whatever right um and so those are
the two biggest areas of expansion from
that perspective um in terms of the
Legion like I don't think the legion
really changes very much I think more or
less it's just how quickly can I involve
as many stakeholders as possible and
make sure that my pitch is oriented to
them looking good and them having no
risk in terms of their job it's like
here's my path to you getting promoted
in a raise and here's there's no
downside like it's all about them you
know what I mean but I think I think
part of it is like and I'm assuming
you're a leader in the company um I
think a lot of it is really getting the
commission breath out of the sales guys
um and oh this is like I'm getting into
tactics but um is you know I love the
term bam f
right book a meeting from a meeting
which is that we never have anyone
falling through the cracks like we
always know what we're doing to move the
ball forward and I think some guys get
tired or they I don't want to say lazy
but like they get tired and they're like
yeah I'm waiting for a response from
that it's like well when are when are
you meeting with them it's like well I'm
waiting for the response it's like if
you're not if you're not able to push
the ball forward from one meeting to the
next like that in my opinion is a loss
like that's a that's like a missale even
though maybe you could save it but you
can dramatically decrease inrease the
pipeline because even setting the frame
with the Enterprise sale of listen
normal Enterprise sales take 12 months
18 months 6 months depending on the
thing that you're selling if you explain
to the prospect you're like listen it
actually doesn't take 12 months it takes
hours hours of work not time so if we
have 48 1hour meetings to get this done
we can just take that and we can stretch
it over 2 years or we can do it in three
3 months it's really up to you and I
think even just setting that breaks a
little bit of the like this feels fast
kind of language that a lot of like more
corporate people will use and then
making sure that the bean counters who
are approving budget like hey I'm just
being real um yeah that that that their
asses are covered and that they can look
good yeah for sure no it's all good
feedback my friend so uh just quick
follow-up question then I'll let you go
regarding lead gen specific you know the
companies we can compete against you're
very familiar with MacKenzie exent right
it seems like a lot of Le gen is based
on content specifically gated content um
and you know part of your value equation
that I really like is you know value on
the front end which is kind of difficult
at the Enterprise level um any thoughts
there moving forward is that do you see
that you know kind of staying the same
maintaining that I think that's 100%
yeah I mean I think it's the same reason
McKenzie for example puts out all those
white papers and Goldman Sachs put all
their industry analysis out right and
you opt in you get it and then they'll
follow up with you and I think I mean I
mean in my opinion this may be an
oversimplification but I'm a simple guy
like I'll I'll get the name from
anywhere in the org that that downloads
the thing that's valuable for them and
then that's where the scripting comes in
of the Judo of like hey you got this
thing what are you getting this thing
for well we're working on this
initiative whatever it's like well like
what's you know you get into s like you
get into sales like what's the objective
what are you guys trying to do cool who
else is involved and then you start then
you start moving your away through the
YG so I want to pull the thread from
wherever I can or sorry get the thread
and then just start pulling my way no
that's that's great stuff man I really
appreciate it uh looking forward to the
new release on Saturday man thanks
brother I appreciate your time